hello class of 2020 congratulations
on making it to this incredible
milestone i just wanted to
personally bestow some wisdom that i
wish someone had told me
when i was your age some tidbits of
wisdom that
hopefully help you to move forward in
the world as you
get out there and uh clean up the mess
that we made
sorry about that please fix it first and
foremost
do not shave your eyebrows it's never
gone well
for anyone took six years to get back to
this this one's still
very sketchy i have to draw it in with a
pencil when you're looking for a new
apartment
always make a phone call in the
before you sign the lease to make sure
you have cell reception in there
when you're at a gas station the green
pump is diesel i don't know why they're
not
more clear with the signage do not put
it in your car
unless you have a diesel car six
thousand dollar mistake
i'm sorry to say this i wish someone had
said this to me when i was your age but
you don't
love him you don't love her they're just
everything that sucks about your mom and
everything that sucks about your dad
all rolled into one that's why you like
him
he also kind of sounds like a catch you
can go ahead and send him my way
also you do not need a boyfriend you do
not need a girlfriend
in your 20s what you need is self-esteem
and a roomba do not go out with anyone
until you've seen their uber rating let
the uber drivers
vet this guy for you just
send me a screen grab of your uber
rating then we'll start texting
don't wear shorts to work unless you're
in the postal service or the nba
always keep a parking ticket in your car
so when you park put it on the
windshield sometimes it works
i don't know if it's legal you should
check that you know how necklaces are
always getting tangled
put it in a straw see that
so that it doesn't tangle up look at
that but this is old don't use a plastic
straw
don't don't be like me i'm a monster
this is old
okay plastic straws murder turtles
if you get stung by a jellyfish don't
let anyone pee on you
under any circumstances in any context
that's not science never get a tattoo
that a judge can see and never get a
piercing
only your doctor can see do not ever
write per my last email in an email
you know why do not give your boyfriend
money
to make an album speed round of things i
wish
i knew when i was your age never cut
your own bangs
do not buy propecia on ebay don't buy
any
medicine on ebay the best way to cut a
cake is actually with dental floss
not in your car with your hands
while crying after a job interview
dental floss
brush your tongue don't get your news
from reddit
if you freeze your eggs which you should
if you can
make sure to write down the clinic
where you froze them like the address
and the phone number get a card
or else you're gonna forget where your
eggs are
it took me three years to find those
this is an important one
if you take nothing from this podcast
this is the most important advice i can
give you class of 2020.
do not send naked photos of yourself
to anyone i know you're not going to
take that advice
so when you take your naked photos make
sure to crop your head
out crop your head out
crop your head out i am trying to help
you get a job
oh and if you're over 21
google wine ice cubes
trust me wait no you guys aren't 21 yet
are you
also brush your hair
brush your goddamn hair and quarantine
damn it congratulations
[Music]